-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy
and Tony Award-winning actor
and one of the stars
of "Dicks: The Musical."
The soundtrack is available now
and the film opens nationwide
this Friday.
Please welcome back
to the show,
our very good friend
Nathan Lane, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Nathan.
-Oh, it's nice to be back.
Nice to see you.
-You're back
to your snazzy self.
You're wearing a pocket square.
You look like $1 million.
-Oh, thank you.
Thank you very much.
You, too, as always.
[ Laughter ]
-You were here right
before the writers strike.
And so we've been apart
for a little over five months.
-I know, I know.
-Did you use the time well?
-Well, you know,
I'm very happy
the writers strike
resolved favorably
for the writers, of course.
And more importantly,
that it brought you back
to late night where you belong.
-Oh, thank you.
-I --
Oh, there was one clap.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because...
[ Laughter ]
Because quite -- quite honestly,
I didn't know
what to do with myself
when you weren't doing --
doing the show.
No, no, I was getting
far too much sleep.
I became downright perky,
and no one wants to see that.
I was so perky I had to rewatch
"The Crown" just to stabilize.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, to bring it back down?
-Yeah.
Without you, the only thing
keeping me up at night
was flashbacks
of the Lauren Boebert video,
where she was vaping
and groping
her boyfriend during
"Beetlejuice: The Musical."
-Yes, of course,
-Perhaps Republicans
should just avoid
theater altogether.
I'm sure Lincoln would have
agreed with that.
Nevertheless --
Oh, too soon?
Nevertheless, I'm sure I'm not
the only "Late Night" viewer
who built a tiny replica
of your desk
and put their dog behind it
dressed like you.
It wasn't quite the same,
but I did enjoy his segment
called "A Closer Woof."
-Oh,
-That was a joke
just for Frisbee.
-Oh, my dog?
-Just for your dog, Frisbee.
-My dog will watch tonight
for the first time
and she'll get one of the jokes.
-That's right.
-The Lauren Boebert thing
must have been
a little harrowing for you
being a longtime
Broadway performer.
Have you ever seen
that sort of --
that sort of beeswax
going on?
-In the theater?
-Yeah.
-Well -- well, sure.
I mean, you know, there --
No, it's a free for all now.
No, you know, but speaking
of free for alls,
I just went to see the Madonna
Celebration Tour in London.
It was astonishing.
You know, we're approximately
the same age.
-You and Madonna
-And I find -- me and Madonna.
-Yeah.
-And what kind of a gay man
would I be if I didn't go to
the Madonna Celebration tour?
-It's like a celebration
of you too in a way.
-Yeah, absolutely.
And I just find her
inspiring on so many levels.
And while I was watching,
I said to myself,
"I need to get a pair
of fishnet compression socks."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But I did think, you know,
it must be tough
to be a rocker at 65
when the only white powder
backstage is Gold Bond.
[ Laughter ]
Too much voguing can cause
carpal tunnel syndrome.
-That's true.
-But there she was,
acting like a virgin
touched for the very first time.
-Oh, good for her.
-It was very moving.
-Very moving.
Now, you know,
you talk about the fact
that you're almost
the same age as her,
and that means
you've had
a very long career.
We obviously know that.
Have you been approached
to write a memoir?
-Yeah, I'm trying, I'm trying.
-Oh, you're trying right now?
-It's very difficult.
Yeah, yeah.
The hardest parts are
the remembering...
[ Laughter ]
...and the writing.
-Yeah.
-And -- and, oh
and the remembering.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, I should have --
I should have written things
down along the way.
I should have kept a journal,
but I didn't.
It's like going into
a grocery store
and realizing
I should have written a list
for what I came here for.
Instead of forgetting bananas,
I'm forgetting my 20s,
30s and 40s.
Cosmopolitans may have played
a major factor in that,
but I don't have
many bombshells
like -- like Jada Pinkett Smith
revealing she --
she and Will Smith have been
secretly separated
for seven years.
W.T.F.
[ Laughter ]
As the kids would say,
W.T.F.!
-Oh, wow. You're doing it in a
very believable kids way.
-Aren't I?
You know, and still
they -- they work together,
they raised the children, they
attended events as a couple.
It seems like maybe
it was a secret even from them.
-Oh, you don't think
they even knew?
-I started to wonder
maybe my husband and I
are secretly separated here.
All this time I just thought
he was in the other room
watching bad reality shows.
I guess I won't figure it out
until he gets up and slaps
someone at the Tony Awards.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, real quick.
-Yeah.
-Real quick, and then we're
going to go to commercial.
But, you know,
speaking of the Tonys,
you and I are working
on a -- on a musical.
-Oh, geez.
-"Cicada, Cicada."
-Oh, well, that's the elephant
in the room.
-It is the elephant.
-The question on
everybody's minds is
"Cicada, Cicada: The Musical."
Now, I'm not --
I'm not privy to everything,
but I've heard that the script
and the score
are still in development.
-Yes.
-And it's not ready
for a table read.
-No.
-But I'm pleased to announce
we have picked out a table.
-[ Laughing ] We have.
-And the good news is the title
is testing through the roof
with both entomologists
and entomologists.
-Oh, that's good.
-[ Laughing ] Because Broadway
has not taken advantage
of the insect wordplay market
since "Spider-Man:
Turn Off the Dark."
-That's true.
-We're on to something.
-We're on to that.
-But we got to act fast
because I don't want
some copycat to poach us.
And suddenly there's two
cicada-themed musicals
vying for Broadway.
-Alright, well,
we're going to get --
we're going to try to get
an actual song
from "Cicada, Cicada"...
-Yes.
-...on this show.
The act one finale.
-The act one finale
within the next six months?
-Christine Baranski,
Harvey Fierstein and the Mets.
-Yes, we're going to get
most of the Mets.
-Most of the Mets.
-Yeah.
You know, the Mets are
very excited about this.
-I bet.
-It's when you have --
when you don't have
postseason baseball
to look forward to,
you look forward to the stage.
[ Laughter ]
I have so much more to ask you
about "Dicks: The Musical,"
which is a real thing.
We'll be right back
with more Nathan Lane.